good morning believe nation today we're
going to talk about how you can develop
a demand and get respect number one is
my personal favorite and make sure you
stick around all over to the end for
some special bonus clips and it seems
that we only truly respect ourselves
when we feel that we are respected by
others and we will go to great lengths
to earn and keep that respect being
respected by others is very important to
each one of us a survey done by the
Gallup Organization found that the most
prominent living Americans rated the
respect of others as the most important
measure of success in life as a result
they worked very hard to earn the
respect of their parents the respect of
their spouses and children the respect
of their peers and colleagues and the
respect of mankind at large when we feel
that someone respects us for who we are
and what we've accomplished we tend to
be more open to that person's influence
did you get the braces guards to treat
you with respect
you're in prison and you said I will
only respond to the name Mandela or mr.
Mandela you must fight the battle for
dignity on the very first day you go to
jail
really and that's what we did it we put
our foot down and insisted in being
respected even though appeasement
and we did not respect others ok the
golden rule you've heard it for years
you've heard it since you've been little
everybody's like oh I treat others the
way that you want to be treated it
sounds simple right but gentlemen I'm
here to tell you respect is a two-way
street
if you don't show others respect and
consideration for their views or
feelings don't expect them to respect
you or yours the deal is we don't have
to agree with people we don't have to
see things eye-to-eye on the same level
but the fact is you need to respect
where they're coming from and try to
understand you may not okay you may come
to the conclusion that they're bad crazy
but at the end of the day you listened
and you tried to understand and guess
what they're gonna respect you for
respecting them another aspect of
respecting others is don't badmouth
people don't talk behind somebody's back
if you've got a problem if you've got an
issue if you've got something you need
to say to somebody say it you can do it
in a respectful manner that enables
communication as opposed to backstabbing
gossip
I grew up skating picture the scenario
into the scenario okay I'm 13 I'm in a
skate park now I'm I'm learning how to
skate okay I'm not the best yet and
there are pro skaters there and some of
them are very friendly and some of them
are very stuck-up they're like oh yeah
they're doing amazing tricks and then
are apologizing for their greatness and
you're they're thinking that's a cocky
guy or girl right
your mouth is opened saying Wow because
they are showing skills that pushing the
boundaries or remember you don't like
them but you respect them you don't tell
them that though obviously and then
you've got skate as an escape pod who
are very friendly but they have this
mindset they aren't good enough when
they skate oh I'm terrible I'm rubbish
and even though you like them you don't
respect their attitude you respect that
[ __ ] over there what's going on you
see there's a hidden psychology to get
respect and feel loved the great paradox
is that the people who want to respect
the most often don't get it and the
people who don't care about getting
respect get the most I know it's not
fair right that's how it goes now what
is that skater who is very cocky but
simply amazing doing what is he doing
what is he doing well he is respecting
himself he is saying I am bad ass I
don't care what you think you say
congratulations I don't care
I don't need your congratulations now
that's not always the best approach to
take but you've got to start there you
see the secret to start attracting love
and respect is to begin code evading it
within yourself okay you've got boxers
and athletes who say I'm the best I'm
the greatest and then they win and you
may not like their attitude but you
respect how confident they are now for
me personally I'm somewhere in the
middle okay I'm a bit of I'm a bit of
cocky I'm a bit of hum
I don't want to be all the way humble
right you don't want to play small and
you don't want to be so arrogant you got
to be somewhere in the middle that's
what works for me but you've got to
realize that you've got to respect
yourself I always talk about realizing
with respect you've got a almost imagine
yourself as this full cup okay a lot of
us have you ever had a situation when
you wanted someone to notice you and the
harder you tried the more they didn't
notice you kind of sucks right
simply because what's happening you feel
you are in a drought and you are because
once again you are neglecting this self
love you've got to love yourself a
hundred percent and not apologize for it
this is not a game no well so you don't
want to take yourself too seriously
either
right a lot of people feel okay they
gotta they gotta bands they live in a
fancy home that people are automatically
gonna respect them it doesn't happen why
because they got those things in the
first place because they were insecure
and needed other people to respect them
certain people don't even have shoes and
you respect them why because they are
badass another way to put ourselves in a
position of being respected by others is
to develop your expertise expertise is
closely tied to knowledge but it's a
little different expertise is the
ability to do the ability to perform
well in your chosen field men and women
with expertise are those who practice
over and over in whatever they do until
they become known far and wide as the
very best in their field your goal is to
be the best at what you do so
question for my buddy Jason here who
he's 19 years old and he's been friends
with his buddy since they were in third
grade I believe so
longtime friends and now that they're
nearly adults one of the things that his
friend has done since day one is
starting to wear on Jason and it's the
fact that he doesn't respect Jason's
time now mind you this is not some
playground third grade
both Jason's 19 years old Damle are a
man and his friend isn't the same age so
he's wondering where is this disconnect
such that my best friend for so many
years has such disrespectful behaviors
towards me more specifically what
happens is he makes plans with his
friend and his friend doesn't show up or
shows up very very late but the thing is
he's always been doing this and Jason
comes to me for for a little bit of
insight you know first of all he wants
to know like what's up with my friend
and should I just move on and Jason's
very specific about it the course of
action that he's thinking about taking
he's considering just detaching himself
completely from his friend and moving on
you know making him no longer a part of
his life because of this disrespect for
Jason's time if you're sticking around
with this guy and you don't have the
capacity to go in and make new friends
this and the fact that he's
disrespecting you in this particular
fashion means that you're being shown
right you're giving in you're given an
opportunity right now you're being
tapped on our kids by God or the
universe or you know whatever it is that
you
the intelligent forces amongst us this
is trying to wake you up to a particular
idea that perhaps you are the link
perhaps you are the problem and
you have some working to do on your
ability to get people to honor and
respect appreciate and deal with you
fairly or your ability to say no and cut
ties where you are clearly being
trampled upon right those those could be
the case may still decide the character
that you are because if I was in the
same situation it'd be a totally
different story I've had people who are
brought into my life that end up
disrespecting me but for me just because
of who I am and that's why this is all
very subjective I have to typically look
at how is it that I need to soften up
see I'm too hard I just feel that about
myself I'm free but hey this is my
natural predisposition so usually when
people are brought into my life that
that disrespect me in this particular
fashion or seem to be wishy washy it's
usually because it's showing me Elliot
relax a little bit bro
soften your heart let this guy in not
everything has to be transactional not
everything has to have a hard purpose
that's what I have to learn it but from
what I'm listening to you when I'm
listening to your question and you're
telling me that you can't go out and
make friends and that this guy's been
stepping on you and you feel stomped on
you probably need to harden up right and
I don't say that in a condescending way
like talking them up what I'm telling
you to do is to do some deep reflection
on why you're letting this happen and
then what practical
magmatic grounded steps you can take to
change yourself you see that's the most
important thing change yourself so that
the mirror reflection that other people
provide you with looks more like what
you want to see do you see it's not that
person spoke we go around our lives
through our lives
pointing at other people as if they're
somehow outside of us but like I invited
you to consider everyone that's in your
life is a part of you you've drawn that
person is your life so we don't fix
other people we fix ourselves so that we
can see in other people what we want to
see so that's it my friend I hope that's
resourceful for you do some deep
reflection about the type of character
you are but the version of yourself that
you are and would like to become work on
yourself and you're gonna notice that
people are gonna treat you differently
for me respect is about setting
boundaries restrictions limits and
understanding what you will no longer
tolerate in your life what is no longer
acceptable you teach people how to treat
you and if you don't teach them then
they're gonna walk all over you and they
won't respect you I had a friend of mine
was on a conversation with yesterday and
he was upset that people were at his
work giving him mistakes all the time
and they're in their files and reports
giving him things filled with errors and
he was so upset that the people were
giving him things filled with errors and
they continue to do that because he lets
them do that because he fixes the
mistakes and instead of just complaining
constantly and allowing people to walk
all over him he should let them know and
not accept it and tell them that they
need to submit better work as long as
you allow people to give you substandard
work as long as you allow people to be
late as long as you allow people to yell
at you as long as you allow people to
disrespect you then they will continue
to do it so it starts with you having a
new base on standard of what you are and
are not willing to tolerate anymore
so that you use yourself have more
respect for you and when you respect
yourself more others will respect you as
well
so I made this video because William
Chilton asked me to so there's a topic
that you like me to cover in the next
edition of believe life leave it in the
comments below and we'll sue we can do
thank you guys so much for watching have
an amazing day continue to believe and
we'll see you soon
stand up for your beliefs by expressing
your true feelings even when these true
feelings are different than your friends
and peers now this step is probably in
my opinion one of the most difficult
steps to actually master because so many
times we get caught up in this herd
mentality we don't want to rock the boat
and we're afraid to tell people what we
really think even if what they're doing
is wrong and what you feel is absolutely
right gentlemen you need to be an
independent thinker in order to command
respect
you can't talk down on someone and then
expect them to respect you certain
people say oh the youth of today of
terrible and when they hear you say that
don't expect a Christmas present don't
even expect anything it's not happening
once you give respect like a game
the players respect the coach because
the coach gives each player so much
respect whatever you want more off and
give it be it go whether resonance is
the highest and don't worry if people
respect you or not just respect your
damn self
Oh
respect is honesty integrity and respect
means
like whatever
I feel respect each morning with my
students debating preview treatment and
respect so respect for me is when
something is different from what I like
or what I think and I'll say no gross or
that stupid essay that's interesting
tell me more about it